just about to start right good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
council meeting Old Trafford District
Council on 27th of May at 2 o'clock this
is the council's first virtual meeting
and everyone is asked from here for the
etiquette the virtual meetings published
on the council's website in terms of
protocol please remember to mute your
microphone when not speaking
if any member present encounters IT
problems causing the dropout of a
virtual meeting they should use best
endeavours to rejoin as quickly as
possible
should the member be unable to rejoin
the meeting they will be a deemed have
left the meeting that point and the
meeting will continue provided it
remains Corot if you have that type of
problem these will you call either IT
and having been unable to hold it i
Tiano 1 7 8 9 2 6 0 0 2 0 or Caroline
Nash democratic services manager on
79764 1 6 3 5 3
if any council wishes to speak on an
item please could you can hate this
through the chat after a lark you use
the chat function solely for this
purpose but the main purpose of this
meeting is to seek agreement to changes
the constitution to enable council to
recommence
in such issues such as planning
committees and others again though
through virtual meetings there is also a
need to reflect the new political
balance of council following the well
put on a by-election on the 12th of May
an addition of one member to the
conservative group as of yesterday
there are however five other items on
the agenda one third counsel from
portfolio holdings which I showed you to
be discussed at this meeting these are
as follows the approval of the previous
minutes Loxley Neighborhood Development
Plan local development scheme April 2020
Stratford upon they traveled on Aven
infrastructure funding statement 2018-19
community struck infrastructure levy
instalments policy
although these are scheduled on today's
items following representations made and
following discussions with the group
leaders and the head of Paige says these
will be deferred to our next formal
council meeting that will be arranged as
an extraordinary meeting it's not in our
current calendar as soon as fees they're
possible at which all what counselors
will be able to participate on these
items
number of candles as part of wedding at
this meeting has been restricted by the
technical challenges in hosting our
first for the virtual meeting indeed we
have had several practice sessions with
counselors present who are attending and
have been one or two issues that have
arisen during that process so I'm now
going to move on to the agenda with that
proviso first item on the agenda at the
core is attendance and apologetic fact
absence and I'll call upon the head of
paid service report take vocal of
attendance and note that those accounts
are not attending have hat are unable to
pen for the reasons I've just described
they will be recorded with the moment as
apologies as of today's date counters by
confirming that you are present you are
also confirming that you can hear and
see the proceedings mr. Buckland could
you call the roll
Thank You chairman yes please repeat
your name and then also affirm that you
can both hear and see proceedings I'll
start with councilor kettle counselor
crystal be careful I can hear and see
the proceedings
counselor Tony balmy yeah I can confirm
Council it's only prophet and I can see
and hear it all counselor
Andrew Crump clenched there Andrew Crump
I can confirm I can see and hear
or proceedings Thank You counselor Tony
Jefferson counselor Tony Jefferson I
confirm I can hear and see all the
proceedings counselor Susan genus
Chancellor Susan Jeanette I can see and
hear all the proceedings
Thank You counselor Tony Kendall
counselor Kendall I confirm that I can
see and hear the proceedings Thank You
counselor Peter Richards
councillor Richards I can confirm I can
both see and hear all proceedings
councillor major Rock counselor Nigel
Rock I confirm I can see and hear the
proceedings and cancer control
councillor Kate Rolf I can confirm that
I can hear and sing all proceedings
thank you we have to substitute members
can't be within the meeting who will not
be participating and tilt unless they
required because I please also check
that they can both hear and see the
meeting councilor Lewis Adam I can
confirm that I can both hear and see the
meeting this calculus Adam thank you and
councillor Jason pointing councillor
Joseph we take yeah and I confirmed that
can hear and see the proceedings Thank
You chairman with a proposal that you
mentioned earlier about the requirement
for us to restrict the numbers of
attending this meeting to the bare
minimum we do have apologies from
counselors Dixon or cog Cargill cleave
Curtis Eddin fielding fitter lemon
almond plus let Ian press tree has live
Jenny fetch Lee councillor Harris has
the Harvey aslýhan show Seraphin has the
Jennings cousin Mills councillor
O'Donnell for Perry of the particular as
we Riley Absolution Tintin
what do you hug ins German thank you
I therefore move on to the person of
interest and I know cancel juniors
wishes to speak can I just confirm the
four subunits speaks on the side to
mother or any other disposes of interest
can exclude or wish to raise at this
point right in the absence of any
exclusions of interest other than
constant unit comes Jenny would you make
your point please yes
I just wanted my dismay that such a
major part of the agenda today was
postponed so late the evening before we
were due to Mont I know that officers
have worked hard and and I can
definitely say that my group have worked
hard to meet all the requirements for
this meeting
we've known each end of abuse we knew
the constraints we were aware of all the
items to be discussed and we've been
kept informed and consulted by the
officers and we prepared our questions
and again we will be fine officers I
think it shows a lack of courtesy to our
residents our officers in particular and
other councillors that the meeting that
the decision to postpone was taken so
late there are serious decisions being
discussed or would have been discussed
today affecting the lives of our
residents and they've been delayed but
no other reason than internal
disagreements and I do consider that an
acceptable and I would like to have that
foot on record thank you
Thank You councillor Julian for those
comments I'm sure they will be limited
as I have said the will cut officers
will be arranging a meeting of full
council with all councils will be able
to attend as soon as it can possibly be
arranged but I take the point as I've
said earlier on point three the minute
I'm proposing that we defer those until
that subsequent meeting in case other
councillors have any comments they wish
to raise about the minutes
unable to attend today you therefore
move on point for announcements and I
would like to open the announcements by
thanking all members of Stratford
district council staff senior and junior
for the enormous amount of effort that
they have put in when abling the council
to continue to run the vast majority of
those services and whilst we have hats
temporarily got the number of services
those mainly were as result all needing
to keep social distancing and therefore
it was better one of you health those
were superior services and our staff
that those were not continued as soon as
we are able
I'm sure officers will recommence those
services certain members of the public
can use them but in addition we are all
fully aware of the additional tasks that
the government has given this council
over the last eight weeks namely
ensuring those self isolating who do not
have a support network were able to
continue to receive vital provisions and
the team led out of the hardly in
Stratford but by mr. weeks we've done a
fantastic job ensuring that those
recorded as in need their needs were met
I'd also like to congratulate the team
led by mr. Platts ensuring that support
for the our businesses who have been
very very badly hit I'm sure many of you
will be aware but Stratford is regarded
by central government as probably the
fourth worst affected district in the
country understand the work that David
Baptist team have done in ensuring that
we have been able to deliver our natural
sport long distances I lost to like
thank the IT team who have an able and
counselors to work remotely and if it's
meeting is the first public view of that
we wouldn't have been doing this two
months ago we weren't able to do it for
weeks so I would like to congratulate
everybody and thank you all very very
much indeed and then therefore at that
point call upon council Tony Jefferson
for his announcement Thank You chair
announcements counselor John field it
was back in the conservative group what
I would also say is the enrollment in
meetings that I've had has been far far
greater and the meetings I'm about to
list are in addition to the routine ones
so the Sur District Council's Network
conference called weekly there's the
ministry of housing communities and
local government update
that's weekly there's a Kovach 19 update
with the county the districts the
boroughs and the local MPs that has been
weekly there's portfolio holders meeting
twice a week there's a let meetings now
weekly these are in addition to the
board meetings there's a West Midlands
combined Authority economic recovery
group which is weekly and I would just
add to that papers that come out for
that usually require about four hours
still be before the meeting and then
there's a Wallach sure recovery group
which is also weekly I would repeat
exactly what the chair has said that we
are the fourth hardest hit district that
is partly because of tourism and just
for information till resume is worth
four hundred and sixty 1.4 million to
the district and supports eight thousand
six hundred and fifty nine jobs because
we are the fourth hardest hit that means
we have been put in the case of the line
we have written to Nadine's aha me
Nadine's aha we I'm Jeremy right
regarding our position that was
forwarded to Robert Robert generic we've
had a response and we have now written
to Robert generic and Ashok Sharma
directly because there is absolutely no
doubt about it the consequences of the
lockdown
have hit our finance is very hard and
all counselors will know there is a
briefing on the financial position after
this Thank You chair thank you very much
[Music]
Thank You chairman I think between
yourself and the leader you've stolen
all my thunder I did want to also pay
tribute to all of our partners through
this covert effort we've welcomed
couldn't be well with County Council or
the town of parish council all of their
banking community groups and helping to
protect our residents over the last two
months the Chairman gave an overview of
the activity that we've been doing
sincere lockdown started in 24th May we
do have our brief in there again the
leader just trail there are four o'clock
this afternoon and also just made
councilors as possible to attend that
meeting because we're going to not just
talk about what we have done or what we
talked about what we need to do into the
future as a recovery effort starts Thank
You Gemma thank you that concludes my
therefore move on to point five which is
the public participation when we have
one question from a member of the public
and that was a question from mr. Stevens
and Norwich chair a Stratford climate
action and he has received a response
from the portfolio holder and we have
not had a supplementary questions with
that response his question and the
response has now been published on the
district council website and in addition
will be available on the team's website
I therefore move on to item and that is
the constitutional and virtual meetings
I'd like couch to turn in Jefferson and
leave your the council
recycle thank you this to return powers
delegated to officers for planning and
license decisions at our meeting on the
26th of March back to the respective
committees and licensing panels and to
suspend member training requirements for
the period of time so the
recommendations and this obviously has
come about because of our experience
trying to work totally remotely the
recommendations are listed on pages 35
and 36 I would ask you to note that at
the time when the council decisions were
taken in March the legislation was still
in its infancy the
coronavirus act of 2020 swept away the
need for members to be physically
present so at the moment if there were
any questions of detail I am sure mr.
Grafton would actually pick those up
Thank You chairman with your permission
I'd just like to address a few points in
the report and then I'll wait for any
questions so in respect of
recommendations one and recommendations
- they're both concerning the
delegations which are listed in Appendix
two of the report which is on page 45
and if you can turn to page 45 you'll
see that there are two headings in bold
the first one is talking about extract
from delegations to the head of planning
and housing and it's just to note that
the title of the head of service has
changed and that will become the head of
regulatory services similarly with the
other heading in bold on
page which reads extract from
delegations to head of governance and
democracy
likewise powers relating to licensing
have also been moved to the Reg the head
of regulatory services this was on the
back of a decision that the head of paid
service issued on the very day that mr.
gender was published so that's that's
the first point and secondly in respect
of paragraph 1.25 of the report that's
on page 38 that paragraph refers to a
decision notice that the leader of the
council will be making returning powers
back to the cabinet it's just for you to
note that that hasn't been done as yet
but will be done when we know the date
for the next cabinet meeting on the page
following it that's page 39 and
particularly paragraphs 5.1 and onwards
it's just to make the general
observation that the aim of the virtual
meetings procedure rules and all the
other documents we've issued is simply
to try to return back to some kind of
level of democratic debate it's fully
recognised that there are some
restrictions in the virtual meetings
procedure rules that don't fully achieve
that that's solely down to the technical
difficulties of holding virtual meetings
I'm keeping my fingers crossed this
afternoon but the I'm anticipating that
as we become more proficient in the way
we deal with virtual meetings then we'll
take another look at those virtual
meetings regulations too to allow
further expansion to bring them even
closer back to what we would term the
full democratic ways in which we conduct
our meetings and lastly and this goes
back to page 35 the first
of the report the third paragraph from
the top under the summary I'm going to
ask you please if you would consider
suspending council procedure all 17.1
this is the rule that says basically
that you can't rescind a decision that's
been taken by the council in the
previous six months personally I'm not
sure that we in Marin if you if you
support these recommendations that you
will be doing that but just to be on the
safe side it would be helpful if you
could suspend that before undertaking
any debate on the on the recommendations
Thank You chairman
you
Chris you're muted
translocate off your microphones muted
we have closed place
do you have a second at your proposal
yes I'm having a couple of communication
problems at this end
can somebody repeat who is second in
comes from Jefferson's proposal
counselor reactions on seconding the
proposal thank you very much we have the
proposal closed and seconded I note that
counselor roll and come to a rock and
requested speak counselor role Thank You
Cass okay right here I wish to draw your
attention to 1.39 regarding online
training I am a member of the member -
does not working group and I am slightly
disappointed that we haven't started our
online training if I can just explain
that that we we are taking part in a
sort of shadow portfolio if you like and
I've had two sessions now with officers
on one to one or one to three people and
it's been really really useful and I
would say more useful than most training
sessions that I've been on and I don't
see why we can't have some updated
online training sessions
perhaps one officer with six members you
learn an awful lot in one hour than you
do in three hours of trading so I would
really like this to be done as soon as
possible because I know there are
members of both of all groups that need
to update their training hours need to
bring them up to speed and I would like
to see this moved sooner rather than
later thank you
that's all right thank you guys the role
comes the rock canceling our rock and if
I may I'd like to make three points
which are really intend to be helpful
and minor comments to avoid possibly any
ambiguity in regulations we have proven
and perhaps mr. Grafton might like to
respond to that so there's three points
chairman would you like me to take the
morning won't go or do you want to do
them one at a time I think your
microphone muted chairman
I suggest come to rock the given this is
our first attempt to best of you if you
get your points out together
I thank you chairman so on page 35 and
on my printed copy goes over to pages I
think there's a word in there which
would be best deleted the foot and point
number five says the following member
training requirements and then the two
support points for that one request
training but cancellations so I think it
would be wise to strike out the word
training because their their member
requirements rather specifically member
training requirements and I think that
beginning on page thirty 7.1 1.13
it's a question about the dating there
the regulations only apply to council
meetings held before 7th of May 20 21
I've seen an explanation of that date
whether that is effectively a sunset
clause on these regulations or whatever
it means an explanation would be
and finally I just wonder if it would be
useful and the VMP are rules that
described in 1.2 - I don't know how
convenient or otherwise it's going to be
to adjust those and I'm not suggesting
that Microsoft is in any way going to
prove him perfect but it locks us into
Microsoft teams some wording in there
that says also the system as the council
might find appropriate from time to time
might be useful because if we didn't
want to switch software we could easily
do it but at the moment we would be
locked into Microsoft teams would need
to presumably come back to the council
to be changed if we wanted to switch
software there just three points
chairman that I think it might be useful
just for examining Thank You chairman
but thanks against the rock for those
points I'm going to ask I can suggest
them to respond first and then if mrs.
if there's any further that he wishes to
add to cancel Justin's comments
Thank You chair I would see no problem
with deleting the word training to read
full following mumble requirements as
it's absolutely correct they are not
just about trading I have absolutely no
idea why the date is 21 but I would
assume that is a sunset clause but
probably mr. Grafton can answer that and
as regards Microsoft teams I think the
reality is that as we move into
Microsoft 365 we're perhaps more locked
into the teams than any of the system
and will continue using that but perhaps
one of the offices would just like to
confirm that
mr. Grafton Thank You leader in in order
of the points quite happy call the word
training to come out on the date of the
regulations yes it is a sunset clause
these are from the remote meetings
regulations published by the government
and lastly the virtual meetings
procedure rule I've issued under my
delegated powers within the Constitution
and as I indicated in the report we will
amend or I will amend those regulations
as we move forward in time so they're
not they're not locked in stone they can
be amended and they will be amended as
we build a fair experience of dealing
with different systems and different
ways of working thank thank you thank
you mr. Grafton Thank You counsel
Jefferson County Pramod you've requested
speak yes following councilor Rob's
comments about online training as
councillor of may be aware earlier this
year I had to give a list of various
potential online training courses and
it's something I have actually spoken to
members of the member development
committee about in the past and I think
going forward we certainly as a council
have to start looking into these sort of
things and I think that the one thing
that the currency treasures highlighted
was probably how exposed we were at how
a big slow we've been in embracing new
technology in general and I think as
councils we probably need to be a lot
more open-minded on that sort of thing
I think transfer homage for those points
Council Junaid give a question speakers
very uncertain times that's exactly when
you need an enhanced level of democratic
accountability so I fully support the
idea that we are going to go back
towards more Dimmick
on democratic accountability really
really vital so I'm glad that we are at
least taking this part of the agenda
today
councillor Junaid counts the crop wishes
to speak thank you
yeah my thoughts on the matter I would
definitely agree with the online turning
nothing that's got a lot of potential
for several areas firstly we don't talk
about big rooms a person could be doing
the training and they could go out to a
wider audience so that's that's good you
get some more people and secondly it's
going to save our carbon footprint by
stopping people like myself cancer the
rock turn okay so the Bromley to have to
come 20 plus miles to a journey it's a
training session so again that's
definitely got potential
now I could see potential working with
other authorities such as our
neighboring ones are there Villa County
or what district for example where
sessions can be run crossed authority
for it for example especially on
planning and again jaunt working
collaboration and sharing the costs
between several authorities so I think
there's several wins are there and again
probably my tribute to the staff for
going through getting all the technology
working and you know unprecedented times
I'll never use that phrase several times
on the press but yeah
hi my tribute to all start involved to
get in the process running thank you how
suggest a new yes I fully support
everything that's been said about
distance learning and e-learning I think
it's absolutely essential the one thing
I would say is any probably picked it up
for my announcements over the last few
weeks the band width in the council has
been pretty well absorbed actually
dealing with the crisis so with that can
I actually propose that we accept the
recommendations on page 35 and 36
very accounts Justin I just want to
confirm you wish to you're prepared to
accept mr. rock castle rocks amendment
to paragraph 5 on page 35 yes seconded
by Councillor Richards you're happy to
accept that amendment a second Thank You
chairman I am happy to do that
I believe I put into the chat point of
order and I believe our mantra often
made the point that we do need to
consider spending procedure rule 17.1
before we move ahead with a vote so I
would like to propose that we do that
please and I was take a seconder right
can we have a seconder for that please a
peach a second Thank You counsel Joyner
I'm just going back to where was council
Rock raised a question about the sunset
date you have new information from
monitoring officer are you happy with
the 7th of May to say as the date comes
from rock if not we are gonna have to
propose an amendment than the 22
secondly thank you I am quite satisfied
with the explanation from the monetary
officer
I don't seek any change right and a
relation to a third point paragraph 1.2
- you've had an explanation again from
the monitoring officer and the leader on
that item are you happy to let that rest
[Music]
under mr. Grafton's delegated authority
it would seem there would be no
difficulty should the need arise mr.
gralton of your three concerns then -
you'll have to let rest and the first
one has been accepted by causa Jefferson
and his seconder
so if there are no other points subject
to approval of suspending paragraph
team which has been proposed down
seconded are we happy to the moocher of
coal to suspend that clause for this for
this moment and if we are I'll get to
our mood after had paid service to run
through and quick Oh
confirm we can carry out that suspension
your name suggests with your four
against or abstain from the proposal of
suspending so chairman of council
councillor kettle car look careful I'm
happy to agree with that preferred a
councillor permits Abramovich is happy
to agree with that proposal Thank You
mr. Crump mr. Crump for thank you
Jefferson Jefferson for Thank You unit
counselor do note for Thank You
councillor Kendall
that's the candle for Thank You
councillor Richard's cancer Richards for
thank you Kozlov rock tested a rock for
thank you and councillor Rolf cancer
Ralph for Thank You chairman obviously a
unanimous support for the suspension of
council procedural 17.1 Thank You mr.
Buckland we therefore move back to the
original motion as amended paragraph I
have amended now we have two options we
can go through each individual heading
one by one but I'm proposing and they
said if we raises a point that they're
not happy I'm proposing that we should
take these items on block are all
members present happy for these items to
be taken on block
seconded my proposal thank you for that
I'm just looking at the comments being
made I haven't got any comments or
concern about that proposal
or I'm going to move that we take this
item on block and therefore I'm going to
request that the proposed got the
proposal set out on page 35 as amended
is put to the vote
and I'll ask mr. Buckland have had a
paper so this to carry out that poll
thank you
Thank You chairman so the vote this time
is on recommendations run through six on
your agenda and again if you could
please indicate whether your fall
against or exciting in relation to the
recommendations careful counselor tackle
for thank you the Bromwich councillor
Bromwich for thank you
catholic crumb coach the Crump for the
Jefferson councillor Jefferson for Thank
You plasmid JUnit 4 Thank You Kendall
councillor Kendall for thank you I crash
the Richards against their Richards for
thank you Bach to the rock or Thank You
councillor whole councillor Rolf for
Thank You chairman that we anonymously
right going forward now I've got a more
level playing field in that respect so
thank you for that unanimous support for
item six on the calendar item set the
agenda and I've already explained the
reason for this but I will invite
counselor Penner Jeff Simmons legal
counsel to introduce this item thank you
with all these political balance
calculation I believe this is the latest
revision to the political balance
calculation I mean these are quite quite
straightforward they are simply a an
arithmetic calculation so unless anyone
has any objections I propose we accept
the political balance calculation
thank you do I have a seconder for that
proposal councillor Richards a seconded
it
council Richards could you confirm your
second to get this cancer Richards
I am sending that puzzle yes comes the
junior to speak
that's the Junod I only wanted to make
the point that I'm happy to accept that
the audit and standards we now have an
extra place on and that will be canceled
and Manuela particular they will take
that place and there have been
adjustments to planning which we are
happy with as well I understand the rest
of the changes are because of the
rejoining of councilor fielding to the
conservative group
they encourages just think very much
does anybody else have any other points
they wish to raise and we've all seen
these calculations carried out before so
we have this proposal has been proposed
and seconded
there are no other comments recorded
wishing to speak so I'm going to ask
council mr. Buckland to move the vote on
this item
Thank You chairman on this occasion I'm
asking you to vote for against
abstaining in relation to the revised
political balance equation which is just
being transmitted onto your screens and
research with uit takes account of the
transfer field you can join me the group
as a service group last night and also
the by-election and welcome to lay that
on that on the 12th of March councillor
kettle
Thank You castor permits Chancellor
Drabek for and cube councillor Crump
okay mr. Crump for Thank You councillor
Jefferson councillor Jefferson for Thank
You councillor June 8 June 8 for Thank
You councillor Kendall Chancellor Kent
ball for Thank You councillor Richards
here Richards before I think counselor
lock down to the rock for thank you and
Prince liberal cancer wealth for thank
you chairman that again was anonymous
thank you we move on to the 0.8 of the
agenda which is councillors questions
five questions have been received which
have been circulated and on the council
website and are available on teams they
brought they've also third being those
questions have had a written response
from the portfolio holders concerned but
in accordance with our normal procedures
those members were asking questions are
entitled to ask one supplementary
question
those responses those questions have
been ported again for councilors I've
asked stuck murder questions and have
received responses details of which are
again on the council website and are now
available on the team's platform all of
those counselors are not present counsel
jr. as I were all fully aware is present
to read out your your supplement her
question concentrated yes my supplement
delays in disability benefits on the
16th of March the government site stated
that claimants on disability benefits or
waiting for the the pip assessments
would not need to attend for
face-to-face assessment assessment yet a
local resident was only told at the
beginning of April that a telephony
assessment would suffice after I took
the I intervened on his behalf and it
caused a lot of problems for him other
residents I know that I've spoken to
have had lengthy waits for other benefit
claims to be met apparently because
staff for the DWP have been diverted
elsewhere
so my supplementary question is would
the portfolio holder please give us a
regular update on the number of
residents that have been impacted by
these delays and whether any
representations have made been made to
the DWP and that's the Department for
Work and Pensions on this subject on
behalf of the residents of this district
you
chairman chairman your muties thank you
thank you calluses Junaid
you've had your response to that
supplementary question from counsel bah
cancel Barca which is available on the
screen and also is available on the
strategist council website so I think
under these current procedure rules that
limit that brings to the end accounts
for questions everybody's had a response
to their supplementaries and therefore
we can now move on to item 9 and please
confirm renew urgent items of business
have been see and therefore it is time
to conclude fab District Council's
virtual meeting I would like to thank
all those officers and counselors who've
attended this meeting it has been quite
a challenging process very grateful for
the efforts made so congratulations
everybody I would also like to thank all
those who are watching this online
Prelude have been the first attempt and
I hope you'll forgive us if we have been
a little bit sticky around some of the
some of the edges we can only do better
with practice and counseling Julian has
asked me raised once again the huge
contribution staff at Stratford I don't
think I physically mentioned the WoW
team and anyone have been behind this
but although staff has made this meeting
possible so thank you very much good in
which case I think with no further ado I
haven't got my gavel here but I now
formally close our first virtual meeting